logros importantes en Colombia pero
marcados por la pandemia es la
conclusión del programa de Naciones
Unidas para el desarrollo en su informe
sobre la evolución de la última década
con un claro éxito
también de esta década pues es el
acuerdo el acuerdo de La Habana el
acuerdo de paz el acuerdo entre el
estado y las FARC de 2016 coincide con
una disminución permanente en la tasa de
homicidios como se observa en la Gráfica
los asesinatos en Colombia entre 2003 y
2011 pasaron de 57,81 a 36,20 por cada
100.000 habitantes con un descenso que
se mantuvo hasta 2021 cuando cayó a un
27,74 sin embargo el informe advierte de
que después del acuerdo de paz ha habido
un incremento en indicadores de
violencia marcado por un fenómeno nuevo
el asesinato de líderes sociales
medioambientales y excombatientes de las
FARC el ámbito de mayor preocupación
para Colombia es el medio ambiente y la
crisis climática
entre el año 2012 y 2020 se han
deforestado más de 1,3 millones de
hectáreas esto es un 71% más respecto a
la década anterior Mientras que el 47%
del país es decir 184 municipios
presentan valores catalogados con riesgo
alto y muy alto en cuanto a la crisis
climática la última década ha sido de
Gran éxito en indicadores sociales como
la reducción en la desigualdad de
ingresos de pobreza monetaria el aumento
de escolaridad y una mayor cobertura
educativa y de acceso a la salud sin
embargo después de la pandemia de Kobe
19 cayó el índice de desarrollo humano
por primera vez en la historia El pib se
contrajo en un 7%, el desempleo creció
en 5 puntos 3,6 millones de personas
cayeron en pobreza monetaria y 2,8
millones en pobreza monetaria extrema
indicadores que el nuevo gobierno de
izquierda de Gustavo Petro se ha puesto
como objetivo revertir en los próximos
cuatro años